these are iodine pills meant to protect
the fire gland in case of a nuclear
disaster they're being distributed
around the saporizia region in ukraine
close to europe's largest nuclear power
plant
since our district is located within 50
kilometers reached from the nuclear
power plant in the area of possible
radiation exposure we're distributing
iodine tablets to people mainly those
under 40. it's happening as the un
nuclear watchdog the international
atomic energy agency is about to inspect
the saporizia power plant
the facility is occupied by russia
and the fighting nearby has intensified
in the past few days
here at ukraine's state nuclear power
company are waiting anxiously for the
visit of the iaea they're not only
waiting to get news of what's happening
inside the plant but they're also hoping
they'll be able to convince russia to
withdraw from the area
russia says it is ukraine that's
shelling the area in an attempt to
retake control of the plant
but the head of ukraine's nuclear
company petrochem told al jazeera this
is not the case
they broke all the rules which exist in
nuclear safety radiation safety and
physical safety of civilian nuclear
objects they broke everything and if
normal mission is coming there a normal
expert will go and see all this evidence
the only result from this mission should
be just get away from here there's also
concern about the safety of ukrainian
technicians working inside the plant
about two hundred
hundred people right now were captured
by russians and actually created badly
in this
facilities they actually captured before
in the town of nergadar and created
prisons their prison
from that and
we do not know what happened with some
people even for we do not know anything
about them for for three months for
example already
for now the fighting goes on in the
southern and eastern ukraine as forces
from the two sides try to gain control
of vital cities across the front line
but at the moment all lies are on the
iaea visit and what it can achieve
teresa al jazeera kiev